hello everyone today we're gonna be
talking a little bit about how to study
effectively I now that I've finished
college and made it through without
failing in the classes I feel like I
have a little bit of clout in in this
area so this is this is more for long
lines for people who maybe have a little
trouble studying little trouble
absorbing information and I just have a
list of a few things that sort of helped
me at time so we're definitely times I
struggled and I decided hey I'm gonna go
basically figure out how to study
properly because doing what the teacher
said was not working which you know the
teachers usually say read the chapter do
the homework okay all right that sounds
reasonable right but the problem with
that was is I just had so much to do
that I would have like one day to read
an entire chapter in like an hour to to
do the homework and I would just rush it
I would have because I'd have no choice
I'd have to rush it and I would end up
usually absorbing very little because
I've just hit that deadline and just
have to be done and so I fill out
everything the best I could and sure it
got me through but it didn't feel very
effective as far as like actually
absorbing information so what I want to
talk about here is more about absorbing
information so you don't have to spend
so much time studying so you can just
kind of hit all the core stuff and and
I'll be done with it so I've got a
little list here that I'm sort of gonna
rip off of I'm gonna leave a little I'll
leave it a little open-ended and this is
the list it was this this is some of the
things so I'm just gonna go through it
it's not really in any particular order
but I'm gonna go from top to bottom and
just talk about it and I might drop a
few links in the editing of this video
for things that help me but that's just
a make
all right so there's some really obvious
things like there's some really obvious
things you should avoid obviously drugs
and alcohol are gonna help you really I
mean some people might say hey they used
this or that to help kick them into gear
maybe coffee is okay a little I think
coffee is fine anything with a little
caffeine is probably okay but you even
got to be careful with that because
after a while it's like you know by the
third cup of coffee it it doesn't have
the same effect anymore so like one is
usually good and now everybody's
different on that but I found if I just
keep drinking coffee and keep studying
eventually I'm just like I feel like my
mind is like just scatterbrained and it
doesn't really work anymore but there
are times when it does to get a cup of
coffee and really focus on something so
that's just sort of a side note I'm not
I don't I don't think there's a whole
lot of substances necessarily that can
help you it's more like a routine and a
practice and a level of interest you
have to be interested in something in
order to retain it that's that's just
how life is
all right so how to study let's get
let's jump right into it shall we
great okay this is a really really big
one that I think a lot of students miss
rest you have to rest I hear about these
all-night cram sessions and not getting
any sleep before a big exam or an SAT
and and to be honest I I might have been
that once or twice but it's it's a
relatively foolish thing unfortunately
it doesn't work that well it won't
really make your grade that much better
than then a short-term study will and
it's basically because you're really
tired your brain doesn't work very well
anymore when you're real tired it wants
to sleep and you're telling it no you
can't you got to keep going try to do
this try to get and it's just like the
whole forcing aspect
doesn't work so let me let me just riff
a little story here or more like a
scenario so one of the things that has
happened to me in the past is I've
noticed especially would like my parents
and stuff and I don't want to get too
specific but like basically everything
my parents told me to do I didn't do and
oh wait what yeah yeah basically
everything my parents told me to do I
didn't want to do and everything they
told me not to do I wanted to do now why
does this make what clearly my parents
had the bed my best interest in mind so
why would it be like opposite now this
took me a while to figure out but it's
because it's yeah it has something to do
with the stuff they tell you to do is
kind of really obvious and you already
know so you don't feel like you're
learning anything and when they tell you
don't do this you really well there's
something there I need to learn about
this I need to learn why not to do it so
I'll start by going and doing it
something like that I'm just gonna get
back to the list if you're having
trouble resting remember that resting is
just about as effective as studying and
this might help you get some rest
so if you're feeling like you're not
studying well and feeling burnout but
you can't sleep because you're stressing
just try your best to settle yourself
you know a girl what helps me is just
getting all ready getting all like I
don't know I like taking showers at
night so if I take a shower and get all
clean up and get all kind of like ready
for sleep that tends to help me go to
sleep and just the thought of okay if I
get more rest this is essentially just
as effective as studying like at rest
for eight hours or I could study for
eight hours maybe not eight hours maybe
six hours or whatever you sleep it was a
little different there but the point is
if you get rest things sink in you
absorb all the things you've been
studying throughout the day kind of like
get settled in your mind and you'll
you'll just feel better whereas if you
just stay up all night attempting to
cram you'll probably get distracted and
not cram very much and even if you do
cram none of it's gonna settle into your
mind and you're gonna forget it probably
you're gone right away so you might as
well get some rest
feel good and effectively you know it'll
it'll help your grade more in the study
and all night probably well so at any
point leave a comment let me know what
you think of these rules or if they
really work alright now let's move right
on to the next thing I have written down
here there's there's such thing as hard
study and soft study and I really don't
remember where I heard this before but
it just like clicked I was thinking
about one day so I wrote it all down now
hard study is like hitting the books
learning the new material it's more
about new material and trying to get
stuff new stuff in like hard information
into your brain that you know and then
there's soft study soft studies more
about doing problems working on things
that involve the knowledge that you need
to know so the idea is usually and I
guess you could do these in either order
you could you could attempt to do
problems our projects news or anything
that relates to the topic you could
attempt it and you'll probably realize
that you don't quite have what it takes
to solve it so then you go to the hard
information try to absorb all that is
you can and it back to the soft and it
takes a combination of both of these to
truly absorb things like you can you can
read about how to do something but until
you actually do it you're probably not
going to be very effective at it so you
need a combination of both of these the
hard studying the soft study you need to
hit the books you need to get the new
information you need to you need to get
the the idea or whatever it is you need
to get that in your head but then you
need to practice it which is the soft
part and once you've practiced it you've
got it out and going back to the hard
study again and you'll just die already
know this thing you know you won't need
to do it anymore
so the thing about hard studies is it's
really a short-term thing it's like you
get the information
absorbing new information and once you
have it there's no reason to ever go
look at it again it's a very quick thing
so you can you can literally study
something now it all varies a bit how
big of the
topic is what it is but basically you
can study something study something
really hard and and then go then once
you've studied it really hard and of the
hard study you go practice it you go do
a project that involves it to your
homework that involves it or what I
found to being most effective often is
coming up with my own stuff to do
involving it because there's sometimes
there's just not good stuff given to you
by like teachers and it almost seems
like they don't know what they're doing
sometimes now this if your experience
may vary but I felt like I had a lot of
teachers that really didn't fit didn't
seem like they really know what they
were doing and they were just kind of
like going in an order based on the book
or based on the previous curricula based
on the previous professor a loud slap
sound was slapping my leg so it seemed
really helpful for me to kind of have my
own stuff to work on at times alright so
now we're cutting on over hard and soft
study so stop hard study is reading
books absorbing new information it could
be other things it could be watching
videos doing lectures about little given
information soft studies doing problems
working on a project or you can use or
anything that relates to the hard study
and practice or in real life terms so if
you learning to build a boat you read
about it or you know hard study could
also be watching somebody else do it
sitting back and watching a master build
a boat and then the soft study would be
trying it yourself but you know if you
skip the whole watch and somebody else
do it you just wing it on your own
you're gonna fail but that also means
you might absorb better when you go to
watch somebody because you kind of know
what to watch for is like how do you get
those seams right and that sort of thing
so there's no best order for these i
hard study sounds better first and soft
study but sometimes it's the other way
just depends and it how it feels to you
alright so hard study times usually much
shorter intense focus on specific
subjects hard and soft combo really
reinforce what is learning the most
so these are the big things I want to
touch on and another big thing that I've
heard a lot that seems to be true is the
80/20 rule and that's basically sort of
it I don't remember who came up with it
but it's a rule that says you get the
most of whatever out of 20% of the work
so say you're doing a hundred percent
study your entire entire bit of study
80% of that is generally gonna be wasted
20 percent is gonna be like super super
good so it's a matter of finding that
20% and I think this can be changed I
think if you if you get really good
study practices where you're not wasting
much time and we're resting
appropriately and apparently the
consensus by the way for how long is you
study is about 30 minutes you're
studying more than 30 minutes and you
start to feel like you're unable to
focus and your mind is drifting you're
probably not absorbing anymore and it's
usually best to take a break in 5 10 15
minutes walk around go do something and
come back to it so I really hope these
tips help people get better grades study
better these are the sort of things that
definitely helped me and that I had to
sort of learn the hard way and you know
I hope you guys do well in your studies
or you know whatever it is this is sort
of geared towards school but it really
relates to anything you want to learn
I'm a big big coders programmer so I I
have to constantly learn new things and
I think I'm about to start a new job
where I'm gonna have to learn a lot more
new things so I'll be putting these into
practice to learn things quickly and
excel in my field all right have a good
day everyone and I'll see you in the
next video keep coding learning and
doing your thing peace out